RETO MEIER: Hello, everyone.
My name is Reto Meier, and
welcome to "This Week in
Android Development,"
November 5, 2012.
Last week was a big week in
Android with Andy Rubin
pulling back the veil of
secrecy to announce the
release of Android Jelly Bean
4.2 along with a slew of new
hardware to go along with it.
It's now possible to get a pure
Android device to suit
all tastes, with Nexus devices
now available in
tall, grande, and venti.
All three sizes will be
available for purchase at
Google Play on November 13.
This week in "Android Developers
Live," Roman and
Adam briefly considered hosting
"Android Design in
Action," live from New York,
under water, and without power
before coming to their senses
and heading home to brace for
Hurricane Sandy.
As a result, there was no show,
but I'm happy to report
that all of our presenters
are safe and well.
It's unlikely that the guys will
be back in action this
week as New York continues
its cleanup benefits.
But as soon as they're finished
bailing out the New
York studio, the guys
will be back.
Meanwhile, in sunny California,
where the only way
our studio will ever be
underwater is when the next
big earthquake hits and tips us
all off the edge of the US
and into the bottom of the
Pacific, Ian and I were able
to host the first our new
format app clinics.
We briefly considered following
ABC sitcom "Up All
Night's" lead in switching to
a multi-camera, live studio
audience format, but instead
elected to dedicate the
majority of the show to
technical tips and tricks that
make a great travel
assistance app.
Last Friday, we looked at how
to use location and transfer
data efficiently as well as
sharing data between apps.
You can tell us which apps and
which app categories you'd
like us to review using
this Trello board.
We'd prefer to review
self-nominated apps, so if
you're an app developer, please
put your app forward
for us to take a look at.
This week Ian and I will be
exploring ways to work
together more effectively by
eliminating the awkward
face-to-face meetings and
corresponding only through
instant messages.
Find out more this Friday when
we look at the technology
behind WhatsApp messenger,
GroupMe, and Trillion.
Tune in on Wednesday for our
regular European office hours
with Rich and Nick, and watch as
Bruno hosts a very special
Spanish addition of "Android
LATAM Developers Live." Next
week also sees the premiere of a
new show, "Table Flip," with
me, Reto Meier.
This week I'll be talking about
exit buttons and why you
should never, ever have one
in your Android apps.
Exit buttons--
not even once.
As always, you can find the
complete scheduled for this
week's live shows at Google
Developers Live.
If you'd like to meet one of
our developer advocates in
person and you're lucky enough
to live in Prague, you can
catch Rich and Nick
at the Prague GDG
Devfest this weekend.
Today's live wallpaper was
"Fresh Leaves," from
maxelus.net.
And remember, to make the most
if this night like we're going
to die young.
My name is Rete Meier.
Thanks for watching.